他一个月挣8000块钱，
他一个月打个几百块钱的游戏，
这个问题倒是不大，
但是如果说非得借钱充几万块钱，
他一个月就挣8000上来，
借钱充5万，
充6万去打这个游戏的话，
那对于家庭的影响就很大，
所以这事候的话，
你再观察，
我跟我老公现在都是29岁，
我们都是本地人，
父母都离得很近，
我们的情况现在没有房产，
住的是男方父亲名下的回迁房，
一共有四套，
我们住了其中的一套，
我们是各有一辆的婚前的车，
结婚两年，
现在孩子是一岁，
彩礼是10万块钱，
陪嫁了10万，
现在都是存在我的名下一张单独的卡里。
婚后的话，
我们是今年投资买了公司的股份，
还有集团的股票，
一共是34万，
其中的10万块钱是我们的婚后才存款，
其他的是我的父母借给我们用的钱，
我老公是从婚后两年都有借贷充值游戏的行为，
第一次是我们刚领证未婚的钱，
父母给的钱大概是充值了三四万借贷剩了几千是她父母给还上了，
第二次是上个周，
我们发现她又借贷了3000，
挣的钱也是我婆婆给她还上了。
上一次的时候刚结完婚，
我们不太想跟他过日子，
我觉得这样比较有隐患，
但是现在我们已经有宝宝了之后，
我想确定一下后期我如何在婚内保护我的财产，
以及为我的宝宝留一些钱，
因为我们不确定后期他会不会借更多的游戏，
后期如果太多了，
我。
不会帮他还这个钱，
我们可能会离婚，
到时候宝宝的抚养权也不知道能不能争取得到，
但是呢，
我的公公婆婆是一个比较不错的人，
他们比较通情达理，
给我们的孩子，
给我们两个人也出钱出力比较大方，
光孩子出生到现在一岁的时候，
这也差不多花了将近有10万块钱。
我的老公工资是定期的上交，
只留生活费，
没有吃喝，
也做家务，
也尊重理解我也会主动带孩子，
我们的兴趣爱好也比较相同，
沟通也比较和谐。
所以说我现在一个是我不知道是否应该离婚，
因为我们的感情除了借贷这件事情也比较和谐，
宝宝也太小啊，
我们现在也有明年买房的打算，
是不是应该是签署一下婚内的财产协议，
或者以后我这个房子的出资应该怎么出，
现在买的话，
如果需要用到我的彩礼或者嫁妆那些婚前财产，
之前我可能没有犹豫，
现在可能不太敢了，
之前听您的直播，
以及我也最近调整自己的心态，
现在有点把我的公婆以及我的老公就当成我养孩子道路上的搭子，
因为我们都有稳定的工作，
他们让我在外面工作一点顾虑都没有，
但是我也想给孩子一个比较有爱的家庭，
但是她总是借贷吧，
三番两次的，
我觉得就像埋了个雷，
第一我感觉啊，
因为他是第二次了，
对借贷撑要戏，
这一次三四万，
这一次是3000是吧，
他一个月工资多少？
我们俩工资都差不多，
就八九千不太到一万，
但年底奖金比较高，
综合算下来。
一年可能20万左右，
是这种情况的话，
协议呢是可以签，
比如说双方没有任何共同的债务，
各自名下的债务由各自偿还，
也可以签，
目前比如说投资的这一部分属于谁的权利，
34万嘛，
其中有24万是你父母借给你的是吧？
对，
就是投资的这一部分利益归属于谁，
这也是可以签的，
包括你自己的彩礼钱和嫁妆钱，
如果是你婚前就到手了，
并且单独存在其他的卡里，
跟你婚后的工资没有混同，
跟婚后的收入没有放在一起，
这个东西它也是你的个人财产。
至于将来的话，
比如说要买房子，
也是可以白纸黑字写清楚，
这个房子是归谁的，
是归女方个人单独所有的呢，
还是归夫妻共同所有的，
还是归夫妻按照份额来占有的，
这都可以白纸黑字写下来，
或者说房子也可以按照份额来，
他们家出来多少钱，
按照出资的份额，
按照对房子的贡献，
按比例来拥有这个房子也是可以的，
但是我觉得是这样啊，
这个事儿呢，
咱说话得说软话，
就是说我不知道你将来是否还能够控制住自己的消费行为，
充游戏的行为，
所以呢，
做这一切的规划呢，
只不过是为了孩子能有一个稳定的将来，
如果以后说你不充游戏了，
咱俩踏踏实实过日子了，
那这些东西不都还是咱俩的吗？
但是在你没有明确借调充游。
借借钱这个毛病之前的话，
那咱就白纸黑字写清楚，
这些东西归我明白，
就这个意思，
可以签协议啊，
以后就算要买房子的话，
也可以白纸黑字写，
他占多少，
你占多少，
大家都觉得说我们现在因为老人面对边都，
房子都有，
都往外出租，
我不确定就我们俩这个情况，
为了以后给孩子一个保障，
是否应该我们俩再去买一套房子，
首先我们是有这个规划，
也是有经济能力，
就是我们拿一些，
我们把我们彩礼下岗钱拿出来，
以及我们公积金里面的账户的余额，
拿一个首付，
我们公积金再贷一下，
每个月还个2000块钱左右，
对我们的生活都没有什么影响，
是否建议我们现阶段因为他这个行为，
我们继续保持婚姻关系去买房子，
我不建议买房子，
第一你们本身就有四套回迁房，
第二现在本来住的就是公公婆婆的一套回迁房，
就不缺房子住，
第三的话，
手上有现金才好掉头，
那你手上没有现金的时候挺难掉头的。
人生比如说你现在手上有个呃，
三十万五十万的现金的话，
不管孩子出任何状况，
你都能够护住他，
你像现在有的孩子，
比如说到了学校，
他未必能适应这个学校，
他可能想转学，
没有现金就好操作，
是不是？
这个操作指的是你可以换地方住，
换城市住，
你都能操作。
再比如说有的时候可能孩子在学校他可能抑郁了，
需要你带着去乡下去。
生活，
去哪里，
去旅游，
你有现金都好操作，
真的跟你们掏心窝子的讲话啊，
所以一切为了孩子，
但是对孩子来说的话，
我觉得我们手上现金为王，
现金多才是好事儿，
好，
我们是不是可以在婚内协议得写清楚，
他在这方面行为的借款，
我可以不用跟他共同偿还，
当然可以白纸黑字写清楚，
我们是一个人各20万，
我其实有的时候也会比较内耗，
因为我现在和孩子奶奶，
就是我的婆婆，
两个人都会比较内耗，
其实我们家庭很普通，
但是呢，
我们都有稳定的工作，
有点小钱，
也没有婆媳的矛盾，
因为我和公公婆婆我们住在一个小区里，
不住在一起，
但是我们的生活一点矛盾都没有，
有时候会比较内耗，
为什么会在这样幸福的生活的基础上，
他还要搞出这样的事端来，
我就担心这种内耗会对我们的孩子，
因为你的父母的情绪会影响孩子的心理发展嘛，
孩子现在刚刚才一岁，
我们会比较担心这种氛围影响到他未来以后的教育，
或者说他这个人适不适合以后作为孩子的父亲是出现在他的生活里，
对孩子有没有影响，
我更关注的是孩子的性格心态方面，
我认为啊，
打游戏，
你说他一个月挣8000块钱，
他一个月打个几百块钱的游戏，
这个问题倒是不大，
但是如果说非得借钱充几万块钱，
他一个月就挣8000上来，
借钱充5万，
充6万去打这个游戏的话，
那。
对家庭的影响就很大，
所以这事儿的话你再观察，
另外的话，
对男人的经济上的话，
你还是要有张有弛，
不能说是他八现了交给你了之后管的死死的，
不是的，
留他自己的零花钱，
他自己自由活动去安有的同学你越管的死的话，
他反弹越厉害，
张弛有度。
我们刚结完婚之后，
我们各自的工资都是各自管理，
因为当时还没有办婚礼，
但是他在办婚礼之前，
她手里应该有八九万块钱，
一下子把三四万都花掉了，
后来我们跟公婆就商量了，
她把所有的工资给我，
每个月有一千到1500，
后期她每个月差不多也有三四百，
三五百的情况，
也是冲进游戏里或者上网吧，
这种我都不太管，
但是这一次可能是突然需要的金额，
充值的金额比较多了，
借了1000多块钱，
而且是比较高利，
也要还三四千的那种，
我们会担心这个利滚利对我们以后的生活造成影响，
因为这次只是被我们发现了，
看到了，
我们及时制止了，
给他还上了，
但是担心后面可能你借个一万八万，
10万、
20万这种，
觉得那个钱用来花这方面不太值得，
我这个人可能比较过日子的，
而且现在都有孩子了，
主要是有一种操作方法，
但是这种操作方法的话，
不到万不得已肯定不能这么干，
一种操作方法就是我俩有离婚证，
但我俩接着过，
为啥呢？
因为有离婚证的话，
就相当于他欠钱，
跟你一毛钱关系都没有，
欠再多你找他去，
我跟他离婚了，
我有啥关。
而且明白，
但是这样对不到万不得已为他的工资不能这么干，
那如果离婚的话，
就这种情况，
是不是他算过错方，
孩子大概率也是会判给我，
他不算过错方，
但算以上孩子的抚养权我也很难争取，
孩子现在才一岁，
你想争取孩子抚养权，
你是有优势的，
本来你也有证惊，
因为我们现在其实他借的这个钱只是说这个行为，
这个态度有问题，
我会担心以后的生活会比较焦虑，
但是现在这个金额不足以构成我们离婚的一个理由，
我也是觉得公婆也给钱，
她也每个月上交工资，
对我养孩子这个路子是个助力，
所以我现在是没想离婚，
但是后期如果特别大是影响我们生活的话，
我会立马离婚的，
所以说这方面来说，
我到时候以这个情况起诉离婚，
或者是我们俩和平离婚，
我到时候能不能争得到抚养权，
主要看，
第一看到时候孩子的年龄，
如果孩子在2岁3岁左右的话，
女方还是优势很大，
如果孩子是超过了8岁的话，
要听孩子他自己选，
如果孩子是两三岁到8岁这个区间的话，
就看谁能够向法官去证明孩子跟着我能过得更好，
能对孩子的教育、
陪伴、
安全，
心理各方面都更好，
是这个意思啊，
那我觉得你心态还是要调整一下，
姑娘要看到你所拥有的这一切，
第一，
现在整个家庭的经济条件是非，
趁好的思考回。
分房，
其中一套用来住，
没有任何的负担，
不需要还房贷，
不需要还车贷，
第二，
自己手上是有一定的存款的，
包括彩礼，
包括你自己的嫁妆，
第三，
还有一定的投资收益，
第4，
公公婆婆在经济上还给帮衬，
第5，
这个男的是有正经工作的，
而且工资也是上交的，
第6，
这个男生本身也没有什么别的不良嗜好啊，
吃喝也没有啊。
第7，
孩子健健康康，
平平安安的，
这些东西都是别人求而不得的东西，
但你拥有了，
你必须要学会每天早上起来就拿着清单算我有哪些东西，
我才可能把日子过得松弛有度，
不然你这个状态太焦虑了，
你老是担心啊，
后老是担心，
以后太焦虑了，
好明白。
其实在这件事情发生之前，
之前我们去年有过这样一次，
比较大了之后，
后来我们因为日子特别平淡，
也特别幸福，
我不会再想，
不会再有太多的这种焦虑的行为，
但是最近又有一次之后，
而且是刚刚开始，
他比较坦白，
这是刚开始，
后面也没有其他的金额，
所以我不是介意他的金额，
不是介意这个钱花了多少，
我们可以拿钱，
日常买衣服，
旅行，
孝敬老人，
吃喝玩这些都没关系，
但是我不太能接受这种投了水里去洒水花也见不着的这种钱，
我是不太能接，
接受这个我也能接受，
说你今天想。
买个什么东西，
或者你想干个什么，
你听我跟我说我们需要多少钱，
这些都可以接受，
但是借贷这个行为他一定是见不得光，
我隐瞒有欺骗的。
红梅姐，
没有别的意思，
因为我每天都是这样过，
我每天早上醒来的话，
先想一遍我拥有什，
所以我这一天过得可富裕了，
可知足了。
好，
我明白你的意思，
谢谢你，
再见啊，
拜拜姐妹们啊，
你每天早上醒来先想一遍你拥有什么，
我每天早上醒来想眼睛能看到自己，
胳膊腿还能动，
还能有想吃早餐的欲望，
孩子乖乖巧巧的，
健健康康的，
不用还房贷，
还有一份工作，
还有那么多姐妹在等着我呢，
今天可以穿哪件漂亮的衣服，
今天我要干点啥？
我每天都这样，
我感觉我是这个世界上最会PUA我的人，
我每天都把自己PUA的高高兴兴的，
每天把自己PUA的满满正能量，
每天把自己PUA的就是幸福指数拉满，
没有什么过不去的事儿，
不是所有的人都能健康的活到42岁这把岁数，
不是所有的人都能拥有健康的宝宝，
不是所有人都能够现在不欠债，
不是所有的人都能够自己身体还是健健康康的就真的，
你要知道整个大数据啊，
总共是80亿人啊，
其中16%是残疾人，
那如果屏幕前的你今天你玄虚显眼是吧，
眼睛能看见，
手双脚都自己能动会，
还能自己做饭吃，
真的挺幸运了，
咱们啊，
记得点赞关注。